chris haynes he's a peacemaker yahoo
senior nba
insider working with nba on tnt as a
sideline reporter
and host of posted up with chris haynes
the podcast
covered the blazers lost to the clippers
pacers went over the lakers on saturday
and you got the blazers maps tomorrow on
tnt
how's morale inside the bubble chris
well i i think it's depending on who you
talk to dan you know some teams are
you know mathematically eliminated and
they're they're eager to get off campus
as soon as um that last game
concludes so for them they're ecstatic
what kind of gossip you got going on
down there
not just basketball wise what what do
you hear what's the word on the street
gossip what you looking for i don't know
i'm just you know
i just kind of curious here you're a man
about town
you got your ear to the ground there i
do
i do have my ear to the ground you know
sometimes my ear goes in place this [ __ ]
and go dp
i'll say i'll say this dp overall
the guys are doing an unbelievable job
with social
distancing and staying in their rooms
and not bringing
any you know company in the room and
they're following orders and protocols
from what i can see dp so i'll leave it
at that
is there recruiting going on do you
think a super team emerges from the
bubble
next year that that one day we'll look
back on the bubble
and these players will say yeah we all
got together and that's how we came up
with this idea
i think i think it's inevitable i don't
know if a super team will be formed from
this but i think it's inevitable that
recruiting is going on and i'm not
saying recruiting
uh i've seen it but i remember the first
like the first few days i was here uh
when i was one of the
lone reporters here on campus and
donovan mitchell and kyle kuzma
were walking around together looking for
food and actually came into the
the dining area which i which i was
eating and i just saw you know i just
found that
fascinating uh and you know those guys
they're close i believe the same giraffe
and uh i just found it fascinated but
that was just the first time i seen
guys intermingling with um other guys on
other teams and so no i think it's
inevitable that
there will be recruiting taking place
here super team i don't know if super
team but
no for sure everybody's congregating is
bound to happen i mentioned that when
the lakers lose its headlines
when the clippers lose it's not when any
the the bucks loot like it's
it's not headline worthy but with the
lakers
you know they ended up losing they've
lost a few in a row here
their offense is supposed to be suspect
here are there real concerns about the
lakers
as they go into the playoffs no i think
there's
there's valid concerns i mean they're
trying to put in a you know
incorporate a few more pieces into the
fold you know they're trying to
get dionne waiters in jr smith um
you know obviously they're without rajon
rondo and their offenses
i believe is still last um during this
bubble right now and so they were one of
the hottest teams before this hiatus so
there's definitely concern going into
the playoffs
but if you start to look at you know the
clippers lost last night to the nets
now i don't know if they cared about
winning that game like do we ignore that
that the clippers lost
to the nets last night no because look
at what doc did in that game against
the portland trailblazers he sat paul
george he said his main guys in the
fourth quarter of the game
and so there are people who think that
they're trying to make sure la has a
tough out
in that first round because they were
basically looked like they were trying
to get
portland that game and that's the game
that you know
you know ended up starting a little
verbal feud with damian lillard paul
george and patrick beverly and uh
they missed two um free throws towards
the end of the game and they lost
and so clippers they're fine with where
they're at
i mean i think for the most part we
understand you know how the clippers do
about resting guys and doing the load
management so
their losses aren't criticized more so
than the lakers because it's the lakers
and lebron and those guys they tend to
play every game
explain to me this feud with damien
lillard and
patrick beverly and paul george
well look man look i will say this about
patrick beverly i'll say about patrick
beverly
he i believe before this bubble started
he said that damian lillard was the
toughest player
for him to guard so there's respect
there like i didn't expect you know the
antics
petrov did like that's expected that's
what he does
paul george on the other hand look i was
at
i was at this nba 2k release party
last summer and dane was there kd was
there
paul george came later and so i'm
talking with dame and kd
and then paul george starts to come over
and so i automatically look at dan and
dane spotson but
that that was it but i bring that up
because
that was the first time dame has saw
paul george or spoke to paul george
since paul george
um you know got bounced in the first
round by you know
that that shot from dame and uh paul
at that time said i believe it was like
a lucky shot yeah that was a [ __ ]
shoddy shot
and so dame sees paul for the first time
paul comes over and i'm watching i'm
watching like i want to see this
i knew i knew they haven't spoken talk
before so
paul comes over and dane you know they
talking paul was like hey bro my bad man
like
my bad i was you know i was in my
feelings and you know what i mean it was
just like the heated moment so
damn they talked and chatted up and kind
of patched things up
but then you know now you know now what
happened
this past time i don't you know i don't
know how dang feels i'm going to talk to
him later
in an interview today but i don't know
really how it feels about paul ray
well you had patrick beverly who was
falling all over
the the floor he was laughing when
lillard missed the two free throws and
paul george is laughing and they're
chirping there
i got those two guys have nothing to
chirp about against damien lillard
yeah like i said that's patrick beverly
he's gonna do that
he does that he does that to lebron you
know what i mean so
i don't oh i got room service coming in
right oh
no no no house cleaning please thank you
no no not not right come back in like 30
minutes please
thank you sorry about that dp uh they
they come here thoroughly was that chris
mannix
that was not mannix oh matt's not
cleaning my room
okay that's not hill uh but
you weren't ordering food that was room
that was uh somebody to clean your room
clean my room
oh okay all right all right well we'll
hurry up then uh we're talking to chris
haynes the uh yahoo senior nba insider
nba on tnt sideline reporter
he's got blazers in the mavs tomorrow on
tnt
i've been talking about uh luca and
at his age i said he's better than larry
bird at this age
larry was still in college so then
people go you know as soon as you say
larry bird they're like yeah you can't
say that
well i have to look at what luke is
doing just the sheer numbers
and i know he's not doing it on a big
stage the way bird did
where they were winning championships
but what luca is doing now at 21
is everybody as impressive if not more
so than what bird was doing at 21
because he was still in college how do
you look at what luke is doing in the
bubble
because it feels like a lot of guys are
putting up some big numbers in the
bubble are these true
real numbers no these are true
look man you can't not dismiss the
production that he's given his team and
and what he's showing you know the
talent he's putting on display and what
i like about him is that
he loves the hoop i spoke to him
yesterday
and you know he's really big on like
team camaraderie it kind of reminds me
of lebron james how lebron james likes
to have
you know all of his teammates with him
you know on off days just doing things
together
and luca is just a basketball junkie and
so
you know he loves his atmosphere you
know he said it's similar
to you know over there in europe the way
you know where they were playing
have teams you know just at the same
location so he's loving this and what i
like about him i was able to
speak with some of the coaching staff
and it was just like
he doesn't overwhelm you with speed
quickness
athleticism but he has a change in a
pace
skill that you just can't teach a lot of
young guys
you know what i mean like it's hard like
you you may look at him like he's slow
he's slowing
he's going by some of the quickest
defenders we have in this league and the
reason why he changes his speed
he's really deceptive in that and then
he has a step back that you just
is unguardable most of the time so he he
has an eye for the game man
he is polished uh i i think it's a valid
comparison when you talk about larry
bird because he was the same way
somebody wasn't overly quick but just
knew how to knew how to use his speed
just right
to get back get past the opponent and
that's why when i look at luca when
people say well would you rather have
luca
or zion i said i'm gonna i'm gonna bet
on
uh luca because he's not in a race
against his body
zion is in a race against his body and
you know he hasn't looked
in shape um and i don't know what he's
going to be like in five years i don't
know
if he is larger um he's not as explosive
as he was
a year ago at duke um you know so i
i don't think it's an argument there
luca would be by far and away who i
would take
zion might bring in more seats more
eyeballs
but you know now you have the pelicans
who bowed out
uh what do you make of their pro like
look at big picture with
the pelicans um cause lonzo was really
disappointing in the bubble
but i do like that they're young and i
love ingram there as well but
uh what do they need well they they need
um zion to stay healthy first and
foremost that's that's the cornerstone
of that franchise and
um how he goes i think the franchise is
going to go as well
uh with that being said you know they
have a decision to make with brandon
ingram he's a free agent this offseason
i was actually surprised brandon came
and played
um in this restart you know he played so
well during the
course of the season that it was like i
felt like he might be one of those guys
to say you know what
my value can't go anything but down
if i go away um but look dp they're
excited but look i want to get to
zion i want to stay on that because he's
the guy when he's talking about the
pelicans man like
they have to figure something out and
obviously i think if you look at the
actions of the pelicans and how they
handled zion
out of he wasn't completely healthy
but you know they they denied that or
they really didn't value this restart
and
and it wasn't our main priority because
they had the easiest schedule
so most people were feeling like you
know the league was trying to make sure
that pelicans got in there and the
league you know if the league did that
or not
we don't know but the pelicans sure
didn't take advantage of that or didn't
try to take advantage of that so
that leads me to believe that they're
playing a long game with him want to
make sure
that he's healthy moving forward but you
know if that kid if he is not able to
get
together physically um they're going to
be in a heap of trouble
yeah i know uh draymond green who's not
in the bubble
was on tnt and uh he was you know trying
to provide some headlines there and he
said the following
about devin booker of the phoenix suns
asking me about it's great to see book
playing well and phoenix playing well
but get my man
out of phoenix it's not good for him
it's not good for his career
sorry chuck but uh wow they got to get
booked out of phoenix i need my man to
go somewhere where he can play great
basketball
all the time and win because he's that
type of player are you tampering
maybe well that cost him 50 large there
what did you make make a draymond green
well i was actually on a boat fishing
when i broke that uh that he was getting
uh
50 000. so that's the first time i've
been on the boat breaking the story
but i'll say that i'll say look it it's
unfortunate i understand why the league
has has to do that um but you know he
was on tnt he was on a show where you
know they have personalities and
draymond
is a personality like i think he's going
to be great for tv for his personality
and for his analysis that he provides
but that's the part
of the player where you know you get on
those platforms
and you know you still aren't free
you're not free like chuckle you know
you're still a player
yeah you know still an active player so
that's the tough spot
about being put in those roles when
you're active player like
you want to come out and say some of the
things that you truly believe
but then you get penalized for doing so
because you're active so
uh you know i think he learned that's a
hefty fine
on your day off when you're in off
season know
that's pretty happy right there and uh
ernie johnson didn't help him by saying
uh are you
tampering yeah but dp i think i think
what
what got on that fine was the fact that
he said devin booker needs to get out of
phoenix
yeah i think that's what it was i don't
think necessarily the the tia by ernie
say are you tampering because
i think once you're saying a player
needs to get out of phoenix that was it
but do you think was draymond correct in
saying that devin booker needs to get
well now he's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know what i'll pay for your room
service if you if you get yelled at by
the phoenix suns
hey uh great just great to uh see you
chris and uh have fun with the blazers
in the mavs
who has more points between damian
lillard and luca
tomorrow night yeah 40
over under is 40 for dame
i'm going 40. i'm going you'll go over
okay all right
all right uh great to talk to you chris
thanks for joining us as always
take care my guy all right that's chris
haines yahoo senior nba insider you'll
see him on the sidelines of the
mavs and the blazers coming up tomorrow